hallo mein name ist lu kann ich bin
dagegen habe ich heute das was weißt du
alles über die quiz rausgesucht das ist
ich muss dazu sagen dass ich bin ich ab
ich bin ich schaue alle videos täglich
deswegen denke ich dass diese fragen
definitiv kein problem für mich
darstellen werden erste frage mit wem
ist da jetzt 2016 scheiß zu beginn schon
ich habe als außer möglichkeiten casey
level 1 tv er ist doch diese nicht mehr
zusammen mit laien ist sie nicht mehr
zusammen mit casey level hat sie das
video gedreht und eugen kenne ich nicht
kann man nichts anwählen rede menem ist
es rappelt in der kiste ene mene meck
und du willst beck ok kate ihre
bescheide schon mal aus jenem ist es
rappelt in der kiste ene mene meck und
du bist weg
ich klicke genannt da gibt's
lieblingsessen pommes salat oder burger
ich salat ist dass das doch gut vom
körper oder also ich finde burgers gut
für den körper aber ich glaube sein oder
ponys ihr erstes video auf ihrem kanal
nicht auf kinos eine challenge mit bibi
no goes by jungs oder fan calls ich
würde sagen eine challenge mit bibi weil
die sind freunde enormen max befreundet
war mein erstes video wenn ich mit max
es war super aussage ich bin ich sage
vanek allen kannte die da bin ich schon
wahrscheinlich noch nicht
dann sage ich fände es ist sowas macht
jeder irgendwie außer ich hätte ihr
würdet euch alle nur abhaken wenn ich
euch anrufen würde
was geht hier ist luca die haare waren
schon mal orange lila grün lila ich
glaube das weiß ich sogar sie heißt da
dies schwester lena julia oder energie
hatte schwester nach und wird da die
wenn du das video sie es tut mir leid
aber ich bin ich bin ehrlich bin ein
großer fan war dani schahin l 1 1 was
weiß ich denken ja ich würde sagen was
weiß ich dann aber ich glaube ja weil
jeder youtube
doch stimmt ich habe sogar ein video
gesehen wo sie da war das war mit diemer
glaube ich schaut euch wenn ihr gerade
zuschaut dann soll da die mal ein video
mit juwi jonas drehen ja bin nicht
überzeugt nein
wie soll ich sowas beantworten nein soll
sie nicht ich mag jonas und ich bin ich
bin nicht ich will dass das das ist ich
bin ja ist ihre schwester älter ich
wusste gar nicht dass sie eine schwester
hat
danke dass es jetzt endlich jetzt
auswahlmöglichkeit ihr gibt das
barockmalerei diermann wie heißt ihre
cousine mit der sie ein biest amber 2
video gemacht hat tina bianca alina ich
sage einfach tina weil es die bibi und
tina die chance das ja an die quiz
ersteller hin oder her der das gemacht
hat warum nimmt man fragen damit rein
wie wie fandest du das quiz nicht so
geil normal halten ich sag nicht so weil
ich muss sagen auch wenn ihr euch damit
oder du oder sie wertes christiane lieb
auch wenn du dir damit sehr viel mühe
gegeben hast vor vier tagen gott der 24
tagen jetzt gemacht auch wenn du dir
damit wirklich viel mühe gegeben hast
mit den ganzen fragen und wahrscheinlich
die antworten raussuchen und so weiter
muss ich sagen diese letzte frage
beantworte ich leider mit nicht so es
quiz war kacke
was weißt du alles über daggi zu 50
prozent sind sie du weißt das meiste was
ist aber nicht unbedingt ein fan dieses
profil hatten 45 prozent der 1222 quiz
teilnehmer die hälfte war so blöd wie
ich mir wurde jetzt als neues quiz
vorgeschlagen ich sollte mal das
bienchen fragezeichen kurz machen etwas
einfacheres zuerst d kanal heißt da die
wie das ist wahr nächste frage ihr
richtiger name ist da die nicole dhabi
hat noch keine kosmetik herausgebracht
oder doch sie hat aber das ist das ist
knifflig weiter steht keine kosmetik das
ist falsch ihr freund eugen a
ich habe vorhin auch jahr gedrückt
deswegen jahr war bezahlt ist die 20
jahre alt
oder ich weiß es nicht ich glaub ja was
richtig kommt sie aus polen glaubt ja
die hatte vor ihrem jetzigen freund noch
keinen freund falsch sie hatte timo dann
gewonnen düsseldorf keine ahnung wie ist
unter anderem mit melina und bibi
befreundet ist war ihre karrieren kanal
gibt es erst seit einem jahr lanciert er
sie hat erst wenige abonnenten das ist
falsch
richtig gut ist schon fast ein richtiges
bienchen sie haben acht von zehn
aufgaben richtig beantwortet im
durchschnitt haben die 398 jesus christ
gemacht haben 801 richtige antwort
abgegeben
das heißt ich bin wieder genau der
durchschnitt damit beende ich an dieser
stelle das video wenn es euch gefallen
hat und ihr denkt dass ihr auch ein
bienchen seid dann lasst mal eine
bewertung da und zeigt noch mehr von
diesem kurs haben wollen weil er gibt es
mittlerweile ganz schön viele kurse
über mich und dann würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr meinen kanal zumindest nicht
die abonnieren würde weil dann bleibe
ich zumindest erstmal bei den abonnenten